لكن هناك هذا الحدث المتفاعل ايضا الذي
نتابعه معكم الان من هاتاي اذا الفرق
التركيه اذا نجحت بعد تسعه ايام من
الزلزال المدمر في العثور على ناجيين هما
سوريان وهما رجل وطفله هذه الصور المباشره
من عين المكان اذا قبل قليل الفرق الانقاذ
التركيه اذا
تواصل البحث اذا تحت انقاض هذه البنايه
كما نتابع هنا فريق البحث يستخدم هذا
الجهاز
اذا للبحث عن اي
اشارات اذا طبعا هذه الصور من انطاكيا
بولايه يا هاتاي هناك معلومات اذا عن
انتشال او اخراج شخصين هما رجل عمره 60
عاما من اسره سوريه هو وكذلك طفله ايضا
اخرجت بعد تسعه ايام
وهي على قيد الحياه كذلك
والبحث الان مستمر عن خمسه مفقودين اخرين
من نفس العائله السوريه تحت انقاض هذه
البنايه كما نتابع معكم في هذه الصور
المباشره اذا فريق البحث ما يزال يستخدم
هذه الاجهزه التي تتبع اي اشارات هي
كاميرات حراريه اذا ترصد وجود حياه او
ناجين تحت هذه الانقاض البحث ما يزال
مستمرا عن خمسه افراد تحت انقاض هذه
البنايه في انطاكيا ب
التركيه اذا بعد تسعه ايام من الزلزال ما
يزال هناك ناجون يخرجون على قيد الحياه
على ما يبدو والامل ما يزال موجودا قبل
قليل تبعنا كلمه للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
طبعا حصيله ضحايا الزلزال ارتفعت الى 41
الف قتيل في كل من تركيا
وسوريا الرئيس اردوغان شبه الزلزال الذي
ضرب بلاده بانه
يعادل قنبله ذريه تحدث بان اي دوله طبعا
اي دوله تواجه هكذا زلزال
فانها يعني ستواجه نفس المشكلات التي
واجهتها تركيا يقول الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان قبل قليل مشاهدينا نحن في متابعه
هذا الحدث المتفاعل ايضا من
انطاكيا بولايه هاتاي التركيه نشاهد فريق
الانقاذ الذي يستمر في جهوده لليوم التاسع
اذا بعد الزلزال في محاوله لاخراج النجين
ما نعلمه حتى الان ان هذا الفريق نجح في
اخراج رجل سيتيني في عمره ستون عاما اذا
من الجنسيه السوريه وطفله ايضا تم
اخراجهما وهما على قيد الحياه بعد تسعه
ايام اذا تحت الانقاض والبحث الان ما يزال
مستمرا عن خمسه افراد اخرين من نفس
العائله
هي عائله سوريه تم الابلاغ عنها اذا وهي
موجوده تحت الانقاذ اذا في المجمل العائله
متكونه من سبعه اشخاص في انطاكيا تم اخراج
شخصين
وباقي خمسه اشخاص اخرين
ايضا فريق البحث اذا مستمر الان وهو يبحث
عن اي اشارات عن طريق الاجهزه التتبع
الحراري اذا مشاهدينا تسعه ايام مرت
وما يزال هناك اخبار مبشره ما تزال هناك
يعني ما يزال هناك ناجون رغم ارتفاع حصيله
القتلى بشكل كبير جدا الى يعني 41 الف
قتيل في هذا الزلزال المدمر ونزوح مليونين
ومئه اي الف شخص اذا نزحوا داخل الاراضي
التركيه كما اعلن الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
قبل قليل اذا مشاهدينا
اليوم ايضا مشاهدينا مع قصص النجاه في هذا
اليوم التاسع اذا بعد الزلزال اربعه اشخاص
ايضا كانوا على قيد الحياه تمكنت فرق
البحث والانقاذ من اخراجهم من وسط الركام
طبعا بعد مرور ثمانيه ايام على وقوع
الزلزال المدمر الاثنين الماضي وفقا
لوكاله الاناضول والتي افادت ايضا بانقاذ
السيده من تحت الانقاض بعد مضيه
200 ساعه في ولايه هاتاي
بجنوب تركيا ومن هاتاي نحن نتابع معكم هذه
الصور المباشره نبقى في متابعه هذه القصه
طبعا الجرافات هي بانتظار الاشارات اذا
للتحرك طبعا كما نتابع معكم كنا نشاهد
فريق البحث وهو يستخدم جهازا للتتبع
الحراري للبحث عن افراد العائله الاخرين